good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday it is
monday we want to cry
but we will sing to make it go by
hey um good morning good morning so much
positive energy for a monday from you
yeah well um you have to do what you
have to do to survive
and that's this is survival this is
survival
this is a super monday monday because
not only do we have a full week ahead of
us
where we just came off a short week that
was so beautiful but we have like such a
serious weekend
yes that i feel like on this monday i
feel like how i felt on last year's
monday where it's like i'm coming back
from the weekend like
bloated tired yeah still hungover yeah
yeah yeah
and i haven't felt that way in a while
i'm not gonna say i'm gonna say i have
not missed it
but it was nice to have such a popping
weekend i had a very robust
weekend i feel like we had the same
weekend yes i feel like it was very
um full in the sense that i got
certain things out of it i was
productive on one day i made an
investment on the other
i partied on one day i was hungover on
the other it had all the different
elements that you really crave in a
weekend
i totally agree it had relaxation it had
fun it had productivity it had shopping
it had rest it did we um we went
shopping on saturday and it was just
so much fun we really haven't i haven't
shopped like that until you drop
no i shopped till i dropped i was like
going back and forth to stores
i haven't done that since before the
pandemic and it's exhausting
you're telling me literally my back felt
like i had thrown it out like when i got
home i felt like an
old woman like walking down the hallway
of my house with my palm
on my hip being like oh like i literally
felt like i couldn't walk
no i know but you got some great things
i made sure of it it was such a
productive day in terms of my portfolio
of investments
um and it was just really great like i
got a new purse that jackie really
encouraged me to purchase
i got a new fragrance which was not
something on my list no i know claudia
and i were walking in bloomingdale's you
know how they always hit you with the
fragrances
and you just like walk down like this
like and you're like oh no thank you
and we were walking like trying to block
it out and at the same time we turn
around we're like
that smells amazing i've never had that
before like there's all these generic
perfume and cologne smells like old
woman old lady
but this woman just sprayed this tiffany
fragrance and it was literally like
refreshing young girl on a beach like it
was so stunning it's the new tiffany
fragrance for
tiffany for love and we both turned
around which is when we knew
yes that you had to get it yes precisely
it smells so good if you guys are
looking for a new perfume like we both
like it so i think that's a really good
endorsement yeah i mean it was a little
expensive for a bottle of water but
it was i wore it but that's what bottles
of water go for these days yeah no and
i've never been the type of gal who had
a fragrance and i've always wanted to be
the type of gal who had like
oh smell that must be claudia you know
like and it's not like a party
true that could go both ways um but your
husband has like a really signature
scent like your
house smells like yeah if i if i'm in
like a public area and i smell someone
with that perfume like i will be like oh
zack's in the room right but it's
someone else
right and because this is such a new
perfume to market you'll be the first to
have it sometimes there is conflicting
and i'm like wait is it her or her like
coming right no which face do i put on
that's gonna be me now
yeah so just watch out i'm gonna dance
myself in perfume every day
and i wore it and then on saturday night
you and i hit the town and i wore my new
fragrance and i think it gave me a new
schwa beef you had
such a joad of eve we also when we were
in the fragrance aisle
there was a fragrance called juan de
vivre which i just like if i ever put
out a fragrance that's what i would call
it joadave jackie
by jackie yeah um yes so saturday night
we had a gno it's been forever since we
had one of those indoor dining we took
full advantage we went to
kaima which is apparently called keema
yeah no they called me to confirm the
reservation she's like hi this is
suzanne from keema i call in to call
your reservation i'm like no i'm sorry i
don't have a reservation i can't have
one at kaima
but um they were finally open inside and
i just feel like my whole perspective on
nightlife has changed let me explain
okay because i guess some could argue
that maybe you know
the restaurant was a little loud or
maybe it was a little warm you know we
couldn't hear each other
yeah no there were like definitely
things about but i was so
happy to be alive like i wanted the
music louder and i wanted it to be
hotter like
i just my bar is so low now i actually
think it's a good thing like i've reset
all my standards
the restaurant was fabulous it was just
music
filled with toasters like legit you guys
it was toaster central and some of the
most amazing toasters
i've ever met but also we haven't like
been amongst toasters in the wild for
over a year
but still like these were some fabulous
toasters no and i felt like this weekend
was actually filled with like big
toaster energy because
the craziest thing happened to me i got
a kobe test yesterday
um me and ben were walking home and the
place is like super close to our house
and we're walking and literally there's
like a car honking and screaming and i'm
like what the [ __ ]
we turn around it's a mini cooper fill
of toasters like
literally full of toasters screaming
like rolling their windows down honking
their horn and i was like
i literally felt like someone was about
to get killed like that when you hear
noise in new york like run the other way
right
but actually this was big toaster energy
that you actually run towards a hundred
percent that sounds
so fun it was actually crazy we're
filled with toasters no i felt like
harry styles like people on the street
like
my name that's really awesome yeah so if
you're ever in a mini cooper and you
happen to see me make sure to scream
um and then yesterday i was just wiped
recovering
and i was still trying to stick to keto
i think i did as good a job as possible
this weekend considering we were
drinking we were at a delicious
restaurant
delicious hungover or just like
exhausted and not being able to like
reach for a car but it was
so hard yesterday uh that is that's hard
so hard
i too have been trying to like cut down
not as crazy but like
i'm going on a trip in a few weeks like
i just need to look my best there's
going to be like some famous people on
the trip and i just want to be like
the cute chubby girl you know and that
takes a great deal of refinement
so i have been just like trying to cut
back a little bit and so yesterday i
woke up and i guess i've only been
trying to come back for like four days
and we'll see how long it lasts but
i woke up and i'm like okay what do
people who like
don't eat like [ __ ] all the time do when
they're hungover it's so difficult
it's so difficult but that's the cheat
day is what people
right you know i was saying though i'm
like i've only been on this diet for
four days like i don't think i've earned
myself a cheat day yet i think
next sunday i could do a cheat day i
agree with you and now it's this sunday
i felt the same way i was like it will
derail all of my efforts so i
really tried so hard to stick to it but
it was it was so difficult i did the
best that i could so we'll see
but um it was all it was all worth it
but that's what i was saying to you last
night we were talking about what do you
eat when you're hungover and it's like
this is why when you're trying
to be on a diet or any sort of plan
this is why you can't drink people stop
drinking yeah not because of the
drinking
or the calories or that but it's like
because the way you feel the next day
it's like you'll reach for anything that
will make you feel better yeah and
you're too tired to exert like willpower
and judgment
you know i have like a full plan like
when i'm hungover it's bagel
the second i wake up before i even get
out of bed i place an order on ubereats
then baco comes in like an hour later
i'll order mcdonald's chicken fries and
a soda
um and then a few hours later after i've
suggested that i have uh pizza and pasta
from seraphina so it's literally like a
4 000 calorie day
yeah and that's no bueno it's fabulous i
gotta have one of those days
so you did like half of that yesterday
less i actually like
ended up sleeping most of the day so i
was like grateful because i'm like if i
wake up like i'll eat everything in my
house yeah which i have done before
great um also the other thing i wanted
to say remember how like last year
when we thought this pandemic was going
to be two weeks at home right two weeks
to flatten the curve we were like what
are you gonna do
when you know the world comes back to
normal and you kept saying it's not
gonna be just like
boom one day back to normal it's like a
slow rollout so i feel like things
for us i think people in other states
are probably more ahead of us
but things do finally feel like they are
starting to take a turn because like i'm
going on tuesday i'm going to a nick
game wow yeah
i'm going to wear a mask i have to get
my cover test that's why i did that
yesterday
and um i'm in a sweet so like i do feel
more protected but sweet you're in a
bruno it's the sweet life
you're in bruno sweet it's a sweet life
of bruno and tiggs they should be there
so i'm really excited for that like i
haven't been to madison square garden in
two years yeah and i'm supposed to be
there multiple times last year two years
crazy right really you haven't been in
two years well it's at least been a year
and then it's like who knows last time i
was at madison square garden got it very
true
yes so things are happening that's
exciting yeah it's it's gonna be a slow
roll and i think that's why it's like
more pertinent than ever that i take off
my quarantine weight
you know what i mean because it's like
we're finally like on our way out and i
just i want to be at my
like feeling your best finally on our
way out so i want to be feeling my best
inside and out but they both you know
lean on the other
that's true so um we have an amazing
show
monday so much to talk about and like
obviously it's so crazy it's hard
it's hard it's a hard monday i'm trying
and honestly i'm succeeding and really
not thinking about it but obviously
today here on the show like we need to
talk about
kim and kanye are getting divorced um
i'm gonna really work through my
feelings on the show because
like i said i've not thought about it
since it was announced i've kept myself
busy
or exhausted the entire time um it's
also the final week of
black history month so today's monday we
are going to be assigning a new toast
movie of the week
which is going to be coming to america
featuring garcelle
and we're watching it because one we've
both never seen it and two there's a
sequel coming out soon yeah so i want to
watch the sequel so i have to watch the
first one and i think it'll be a great
movie for us all to watch it's available
on um amazon prime to stream for free so
use your prime membership or steal
someone you know can't wait also we have
a great tv recap i spent most my weekend
watching downton abbey so
fabulous but we have to talk about real
housewives of atlanta oh
wait the episode of the year we actually
have to talk about
it was the best episode of tv like i've
literally ever seen also really quickly
i want to talk about rupaul's drag race
for two seconds just enter it just
indulge me
it was one of those episodes spoiler
alert
where nobody went home like they sent
candy muse home but then as she's
walking by rue used like his one
immunity card and was like
candy you can stay and candy's my
favorite but she's not a winner like
and even though she really um is there
like
because she's a 10 out of 10
entertainment-wise like in when they're
all doing glam like she's the one who's
being crazy and funny
but it's a competition and unfortunately
she's my favorite and it pains me to say
like she's not a winner she's not even
close
no but she's miss congeniality by the
way they do give out miss congeniality
oh
at the uh reunion and she is 100 even
though she's not like the nicest
everyone she's actually always starting
drama
um she's actually definitely not miss
congeniality for the audience i think
everyone loves her but like we know
she's not
her looks aren't there her performances
are not there but i'm really struggling
because
do you see how rihanna um messaged
heather gay yeah rihanna was obviously
on some sort of reality tv kick because
she also
messaged simone who i thought for the
longest time like is definitely the
winner
um like her looks are just like you like
you would think it's rihanna i'm not
surprised rihanna damned her she's
definitely like so inspired by rihanna
her looks are so sickening she has this
like amazing attitude like the way
that she walks but all these recent
challenges have been like acting
challenges
music challenges dancing challenges and
simone is giving me nothing like
literally nothing and this is what i
always say it's like
in order to win rupaul's drag race it's
always like you always think like the
obvious choice is the one with the best
looks but there's so much more to being
a drag queen than the looks it's like
you have to be a performer you have to
be able to do a little bit of everything
stand up you have to do they do stand up
challenges they do musical challenges
dance challenges
acting you have to have all the elements
and sometimes like the most popular
girls by lachochi
gigi good are like literally just models
like you never saw anyone so stunning in
your whole life
with the best style but they give you
nothing else and so it's easy to like
want those girls to win like i really
wanted gigi good to win but at the end
of the day like she gave me nothing like
yeah ever
violetki was like a little too sickening
not to win
but sometimes you're like oh well why
did bob the drag queen win because he's
not always like the most sickening
but it's like he had everything like
comedy but
so now back to my original point i don't
think simone like has
all the elements that's what i've
learned even though like to me was so
clear that she was the winner
so now i'm really questioning and i have
something crazy to say because i've been
like on this journey with like who i
like who i don't like
rose is kind of everything of the sort
and i still really i'm not
like feeling denali i just think like
i'm just not there yet with her but rose
is one to watch so that's what i'll say
and even though i'm glad candy muse is
still around because she's literally my
favorite queen of all time
and i would love to see a bigger queen
win like the
maybe once a season no one contestant a
season is like plus size and
they never really make it far except
eureka eureka did make it pretty far
but i would love to see like a a bigger
plus-sized queen succeed
i don't think that that's gonna be candy
because she's just
she's not there yet but at least she's
still around yeah i know and she's
everything of the sort like
she did the way she talks like what she
says she
she literally she has a lisp and they
did this musical where you have to lip
sync and like her characters
um lip syncing like had so many s words
and she was like of course
like i get the one with the s and she's
like i know nobody can understand what
i'm saying half the time i bet you guys
are using subtitles right now she said
that in her confessionals and they're
literally using subtitles but she's just
everything of the sort like she's a
confidence queen but
i'm glad she's still around but it won't
be much longer okay and if ellie with
two tease doesn't go home soon like i'm
going to stop watching
that's that's my shield sorry no that's
great i heard drag race uk this season
is so good i just like my plate is so
full
but maybe if i get bored enough like on
a plane or something
like i have so many places to go but if
i get bored enough like i will watch it
yeah i feel you my plate is so so full
so full and not in the good way
not with food with content totally we
have the bachelor tonight it's just like
a bit
we're just back you know weekend was
here and now it's gone it's
very very true so without further ado
let us get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
you know what i'm feeling stressed
there's so much
turmoil around me no thank god i've got
my new ex cbd
their mission is to provide customers
with the highest quality products
at a reasonable price they have years of
experience in sourcing manufacturing and
developing
and their goal is to make cbd accessible
to the masses they never sacrifice
quality and all of their products are
natural
pure and tested so i've been on the cbg
journey now for like two years and i've
tried
many products and i have to say new x is
very good they're very consistent i love
their gummies
and they're probably the most reasonably
priced um
cbd products that i've seen on the
market because
some of these companies are getting out
of control like new x is always keeping
their products good
and reasonably priced they have a few
products i obviously like the gummies
because i love a snack
they taste really good um they're vegan
if you care made with all natural
ingredients no artificial colors flavors
or sweeteners
and they have 15 milligrams of broad
spectrum cbd per gummy
the dosing is really even which is why i
like it they also have
shots like a little tincture in the
words of shannadur i love it
it's 150 milligrams of caffeine an
energy blend and 30 milligrams of cbd
it's super easy to drink it's a two
ounce bottle
it's mango flavored again non-gmo vegan
made with full spectrum usa grown hemp
so if you've been looking to get into
cbd or you're trying to up your cbd
journey
new x is a brand that i've been using
for a while they've been sponsoring the
show for a while and i really enjoy
and i think you guys should check it out
new x's nu-x dot com if you want to
purchase some of their products
you can use the discount code toast for
20 off for a limited time
that's new x n u dash x dot com
promo code toast yes okay we're gonna
need some cbd after this announcement
kim kardashian has filed for divorce
from
kanye west citing irreconcilable
differences she has requested joint
legal and physical
custody of their kids which is you know
a good sign in terms of the
amicability yeah because i was just
watching mrs doubtfire over the weekend
and you really forget how [ __ ] up it
was that sally fields like would not let
her kids see their dad even though he
was not like a deadbeat dad he had lost
his job and he was working on getting
his apartment
because she kicked him out of the house
right he just had a lot going on at the
moment but he was such a devoted dad
by the way such a good dad like it's
actually a really sad movie if you watch
it now
one because robin williams is no longer
with us so it's like you feel sad and
then it's like
sally field like lighten the [ __ ] up i
know and she's my birthday buddy
i know i know it's a really hard pill to
swallow yeah no and she's like
just moving on so fast with pierce bros
and it's like robin williams still
hasn't even unpacked his boxes in his
new apartment
hundred percent it's like as if it
couldn't get worse james bond
oh yeah pierce brosnan right um no
you're right it's actually like a
tragedy the movie like except the best
scene ever is harvey fierstein making
them making
uh robin williams into mrs doubtfire
it's honestly such a good movie
i really appreciate your efforts to
distract once again from the story at
hand
but what i was going to say was that i
actually read the
the public uh court documents are public
okay
and it's cited that the irreconcilable
difference was
the moment that kanye tweeted that he
doesn't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] stormy loki
was really when the the marriage ended
he said he doesn't [ __ ] with stormy
yeah he put up a tweet when he was you
know tweeting
a lot and he said loki i don't [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] storming he really said that
yes
and that's it it said that in the
documentary oh i made that up oh okay
you can't just be slave
i don't know what did you know what
happened is true and what like
if it's a joke based on truth i don't
know where the truth lies i thought like
you're
uh you know a kimmy historian i thought
you knew that he tweeted that i
have just brushed all of this to the
side i know but here we are having to
deal with it they are getting divorced
apparently and no not apparently they
are
yeah allegedly and the denial
knows no you know what it is what it is
it is what it is you know i think that i
will continue to support
each member i will continue to stand
and i just hope that they both find
happiness and what's best for each of
them and i hope that the kids
i mean i think 50 50 join custody like
means that they're they're pretty
they're good and that the kids will you
know spend half their time with each and
that's good for that sounds as good as
it can get yeah
i want to say two things one i think
like we shouldn't all forget like we are
dealing with someone who's struggling
with mental illness and like that is
really sad
and i'm sure it's been like so hard for
kim these last few years so i just think
like there should be a level of
sensitivity
the way people like especially like the
media talk about kanye like he's crazy
like no
he's suffering first of all second of
all i kind of
love that like kim is now gonna not that
you know it's sad obviously not to see
your kids but they're gonna be with
their dad 50
of the time like maybe we can get some
nice like single energy kim like
going out to the clubs like when we're
allowed yeah
i guess i love drunk kim come on be
positive come on no i i i
am but first of all i just don't i think
that they were just everything of the
sort like i just don't know where you go
from there when you're like
they're as a-list as it gets like you
know
she could date someone like kanye
adjacent sure
but it won't be the same it won't be the
same no you're right i don't know where
we
go from here specifically i i don't know
if either one of them are looking to get
into another relationship i think that
kanye's probably going to focus on
himself and his business and his kids
and i think that's
the best for kim like maybe that each
one of them will fall into love but i
don't think they're like seeking it out
like they have four kids they have
many businesses like uh i do think
eventually like they will find love but
i don't think that's
that's like their immediate goal it's
just so crazy because i feel like for so
long so much of kim's brand and her fame
was like who's kim dating who's kim
dating
and now so for the last like 10 years
kim's whole brand has been like
family girl she's really like changed
her image so well she went from being
like a
you know sex icon to being like a family
woman
and now it's like where do we go from
here what's next i'm also curious like
what this means
not the immediate future but like in the
what this means for like their fashion
the whole family's
fashion has been completely influenced
and changed by kanye and so i wonder
what they'll just keep wearing what
they're wearing we can go back to middle
parts and skinny jeans and blazers
no but like whatever they're going to be
wearing in three years is not what they
would have been wearing if kanye were
still in the family no that's 100 true
they've all really emulated that like
toned down
nude vibe yeah so that part will be very
interesting
i'm just going to continue to process
this as i have been which is really not
to
not to think about it and then enough
time will go by where it's just fact
where it's just
a part of your life i think i can like
skip over the grieving process if i try
hard enough i really do
yeah i mean that's not healthy no it's
not but i think it's okay
in this circumstance okay you know
because it's it's far enough out of my
life that it doesn't like i don't need
to process it
so deeply yeah but i also like don't
need to live with that pain right now
i just feel sad i really do like i
wanted this so badly for kim and i loved
that like she
she i'm just sad i'm i'm sad for kanye
too like
of course of course just the way that he
like talks about kim and like living for
him and always has
like yeah and for him too i think
there's so much like
we can learn from their story like what
and when we watch the
true hollywood story which whatever
happened to that reboot
i can't it's another reason to start
doing reboots
the e-network is so messy um
when kim said like in terms of like her
place in the fashion world like people
only started taking her seriously
when she started dating kanye because at
first she was just like you know
this like reality star who nobody really
thought much of and then kanye gave her
like this level of
gravitas and the way they spoke about
how like he was just like so proud to
always be with her even though like
in his circle she was like considered
you know kind of derek
yeah so the way they always spoke about
like the respect they had for one
another in the beginning of their
relationship is always like what i
like loved about their relationship so
much and
now it's for naught no it's for naught
well not for not they have four
beautiful children hopefully and you
know being a child of divorce
ourselves um it'll be fine they'll
they'll be okay they'll have two big
houses
north you know oh she's she's going to
be going through some stuff
yeah but i think she'll channel it
creatively and artistically and i look
forward to seeing what paintings we get
her next her next piece
yeah it's going to be maybe darker you
know 100 stormy clouds
storms instead of like a sunny day
stormy by north
that's good thanks thanks well we're
wishing everyone the best you know
divorces are really hard i watched a
marriage story
and we're just wishing everyone the best
hopefully we can end this amicably you
know assets
yeah i just hope it's all as amicable as
it sounds and that you know they can
just
part in the easiest way possible for two
mega stars
yeah well there is um some like pending
lawsuits against easy
that i think part of the reason why i
saw this honestly
yeah i saw that yeah and i learned i
didn't even know that was a thing but i
learned that with chris and justin
hartley like
in california the date of separation is
like super important because that's when
like your assets become officially
separate
so you have to make it really public
when your date of separation is and i
guess that's why there were so many news
articles about kim and kanye because
even though they've known for a while
um they needed they needed like the
paper trail out there
okay well we'll keep you posted um just
to all the kimmy stands like i see
you i feel you and we're gonna be okay
we're gonna get through this we're gonna
beat
all right it's gonna be okay
speaking of music um snl this weekend
put out a sketch
of the about driver's license the song
and
for the first time in a long time they
completely hit
the nail on the head i agree i was
actually really shocked
that they even addressed it because snl
i think tends to
skew a little bit older whereas
tick-tock driver's license
gen z it's like all a much younger
demographic and so i was surprised
honestly i don't know this for a fact i
just feel like bowen yang who is
obsessed with tick tock like it was
definitely his idea like i just know it
100
and i just think he's actually like the
best thing that snl has ever done
i completely the best decision they ever
made and also chloe feinman
i completely agree about boning and so
the sketch was if you haven't seen it
yet go see it so many people were like
tagging us like this reminds me
of the morning toast because it's like
basically all these guys at a bar
like playing like in queens they have
like new york italian accents
and like the song driver's license comes
on and like it turns out that they all
know the song know exactly what it's
about and like
are so into it which is really like how
the song has taken the world by storm
um it's a it's a really great sketch but
olivia rodrigo and joshua bassetts have
have reacted to it
now so um she posted driver's license
snl sketch is the best birthday present
ever i'm
shaking and then he posted a really
funny tip where it's like oh someone
said there's an snl sketch about you and
then
he goes and watches and it's like one of
the guys my [ __ ] ex gina is
joshua bassett yeah which is just really
funny and then he plays happy and sad at
the same time by casey moss graves
and i actually thought that was a very
mature funny reaction and he got some
kudos
you know from youtube points yeah wow
yeah one of the biggest joshua basset
detractors
haters like haters 100
so um good for snl for like really
keeping up with the zeitgeist
yeah and um reggae jean-paul from
bridgeton
was the host and i also feel like
because he was there like it made it the
sketch even better because he is so
gen z and i feel like he's like i feel
like the sketch might have not happened
without him but i don't know that
yeah well i have to say i watched a
bunch of the sketches
on youtube and you know
i was really taken taken by him like
obviously he's super handsome and like
everyone knows that and but there's a
lot of very handsome actors
who don't go on to become huge mega
stars um
and watching him he has it
like he has the star quality like yeah
he is a star like he was funny i you
know i'm used to on snl nobody memorizes
their lines they have cue cards and it's
like kind of distracting because like
i'll be talking to you but i'll be
looking over here at my cue cards like
hey jackie
what'd you have for lunch like you're
also looking at the audience it's a lot
it's hard
but i believe he memorized most of his
lines because when i was watching he
appeared to be reading them from memory
and he just like really
i was very impressed by him like his
monologue was great he was funny he was
self-deprecating
he has star quality like he will
bridgerton will not be a flash in the
pan like he is going to be
i have a feeling you're hearing it first
wow oh also
speaking of snl two more things i want
to talk about but one nick jonas just
announced
we have to talk about that he um is
going to be hosting and performing on
snl
next week a solo performance of a new
song called spaceman
yeah and i heard i can't verify this for
real but
i did hear he um you know obviously no
shade to priyanka but
he didn't meet someone and he was so
inspired by their
joadave that he wrote spaceman
about um for chairman that's who he is
but he didn't want to give too much away
he knows that theo is a private like
right so he called it specimen instead
of fachem
but i really look forward to hearing the
song that he wrote about theo yeah to be
honest like when i saw the card
people like love to photoshop the snl
announcements
so i thought it was fake like i don't
know like scaring jonas brothers fans
into thinking they're breaking up again
and i'm like oh well but then i saw nick
jonas tweeted it so i'm like oh man no
this is actually
real and also it begs the question like
what's going on with the jonas brothers
i personally think it's like nick jonas
was just working on some stuff
in the queue like wants to put it out
there that's always how it starts though
and like
i'm just not ready to go through this
rollercoaster of emotions again like if
jonas brothers
if they're all doing solo endeavors
again like that's it for me yeah i just
can't keep going up and down no the
thing is is like
when they got back together they never
said it but i think the fandom and
everyone like it was under the
assumption like it was
for good like there's no more like
breaking up right we watched that
documentary where they literally said
like we're going to like
if we're doing this basically said
there's no more breaking up yeah
basically
and so not only are they a band but
they're also brothers so i think like
them being brothers gave us more faith
like
you know family sticks together so i'm
like okay you know if they get back
together like this time's for real
and i'm not saying that him performing
on snl automatically means that they're
breaking up
but it's not a good sign and i'll just
say that yeah it's not a good sign
when i saw it i was like i really
thought it was like there's a difference
between like working on some solo music
putting it out seeing like
getting feelers there's a difference
between that and like
doing that on snl you know that's like a
solo act hi this is me
i'm here nick jonas yeah like i'm coming
in and i'm performing nick jonas yeah
hosting
and performing is like big yeah it's
like i'm making a big splash in the
music industry yeah and people who do
that are usually promoting something
like
huge like not anyone can just roll in
and perform and host at the same time
it's like you have a big project you're
promoting
so again it's not an album not saying
this means anything but it
but it doesn't mean nothing unless the
jonas brothers like come out for a song
then i'll feel good but i doubt that
they will oh they might
you never that is actually because he
has to perform two songs he's only
really sing one song but he's gonna sing
one of his solo songs from 10 years ago
that would make it okay if the jonas
brothers come out for one of the songs
then i'm like okay they're supporting
his new endeavor
yeah he obviously was just getting his
artistic uses flowing i could just see
like an amazon prime documentary in five
years from now like referencing
this moment yeah when we knew it was all
over right like they always talk they
talked about in the documentary like
when nick and joe did that z100 radio
jingle ball performance like that was
like a moment for kevin where he was
like so hurt he wanted out
i feel like in five years we will find
out that like this snl like you know
joe and kevin like they didn't know they
didn't found out on instagram they were
like
he wants space man oh my god
he can have his space you're right
spaceman
man just thinking we'll have to read
into the lyrics of the song when they
come out of course just like driver's
license the other thing about snl that i
wanted to talk about is a joke that
michael che made on weekend update
about israel and their vaccine roll out
he israel has vaccinated 50
of their population they are the leading
country in the vaccine rollout they're
actually doing an amazing job
and michael yeah i actually saw a bar
giving out vaccines like buy a drink get
a vaccine
wow i've got to get to tel aviv for a
drink yeah
michael che said israel is reporting
that they vaccinated half of their
population i'm going to guess it's the
jewish half
which i find to be a very offensive joke
rooted in
bias and uh misinformation about bad
stereotypes about jews that have existed
forever
right and i just think that a joke about
in this fashion about any other religion
would never fly
yeah and here's my thinking here's my
thing because i've spoke to you about
this morning and
i'm very much on the side of like a joke
is a joke like i really believe that and
like
but you did point out and and i do agree
like
a joke is a joke yes but snl for like
the last 10 years hasn't been
like you know the pinnacle of comedy
they're they're on tv they're
very um you know conservative in their
jokes like they don't make crazy jokes
anymore you watch stuff that used to
happen on snl you're like oh my god i
can't but
i can't believe that this was on tv now
it's like it's kind of
not pg but it's just it's not outlandish
it's not a yes it's humor
yeah it's not it's not good right it's
just not crazy humor anymore so i feel
like
for snl to have made this joke it's very
uncharacteristic of them like they don't
make jokes like that anymore like
i think a lot of comedy over the last 10
years is about like certain cultures or
stereotypes
and that has been deemed inappropriate
by like wool culture
so snl doesn't do that anymore so the
fact that they did it
about jews like does feel like once
again like
as jews and maybe people who aren't
jewish don't understand it just feels
like
you know it's not okay to say anything
about other cultures but like when it
comes to us like we always feel like
it's fine like people are always joking
about us
right um i feel torn because like a joke
is a joke but you can't help but think
what is the root of the joke either you
make jokes about everyone
or you make jokes about no one yeah and
you don't just just make jokes about one
group of people also
then i saw a clip i don't know when this
episode aired it was about like a miss
hitler pageant that was taken it was
2020 may 2020. oh okay so not that long
ago may 2020
um there was a miss hitler pageant that
was taken off of godaddy
and then michael che made a joke oh and
the winner of the miss hitler pageant
was miss
israel yeah no now it feels like is it a
pattern is it a pattern where is it
coming from
so i'm inclined to just like brush it
off like a joke is a joke everyone gets
made fun of but on snl it's like
actually no not everyone gets made fun
of so like when you feel singled out
like
it does feel like do you have a problem
with me michael chelsea right let's talk
about it i just
yeah i i i'm not here for it
i think that it it also then like
perpetuates this
negative stereotype about jews about
israel and i think it's just a dangerous
road to go on especially because it's so
untrue because it's so untrue and what
israel is doing with vaccinations is
like
should be admired should be admired and
is admired by
everyone by the way it's not first of
all just to put facts out there
it's not only the jew it's not true half
the population has been
vaccinated they're doing like the best
and the most they're the most far ahead
of any other country
they have christian citizens muslim
citizens drew citizens and jewish
citizens
who all have equal access to the vaccine
so it's just worth noting like
maybe if you heard the joke you don't
think much of it but like it's not true
right
but also maybe you feel this way too
like i think probably other
cultures feel this way as well like i
just like hate to be like naggy like
it's anti-thematic you know what i mean
like
you just feel annoying pointing it out
but it's like you also get a pit it's
like oh man this is what people think of
us like yeah
so i actually think a lot of people can
relate to that like i'm always inclined
to be like it's
fine you know like it's a joke just
because like i hate to be
like that girl again you know like she's
i was complaining
is i do feel that way a lot of the time
and i and so i feel like
i don't bring up on this show like a lot
of things that i find offensive yeah but
snl is such a huge platform like
and also i don't know he's inclined to
give people the benefit of that
i'm not saying like i'm not saying that
i don't know michael j i'm not saying
he's anti-semitic i don't know him i
don't know that he is but this joke
i find to be anti-semitic and i think
that he should apologize yeah
i mean i agree like i'm torn because
like i'm really especially
like because like comedy is comedy but
it's like i said i was like not even
comedy anymore right they're just like
it's like a show like i can't explain it
so like if if someone had said this in a
comedy club like maybe it wouldn't have
bothered me so much because like people
are allowed to joke they are
but like when snl has just become like
so sensitive to like
everything in the world except for me
like why
but not for me so yeah but i really do
try so hard to give people the benefit
of the doubt like i feel and you know
what i feel like a lot of times it pays
off like i feel like when we were
talking
earlier in the year about last year
about nick cannon
i feel like we really gave him the
benefit of the doubt and i think he
he and i think he's a great example of
like why you shouldn't just write people
off maybe you should like help them
instead of
cancelling them like pulling away like
taking away all of his jobs all this
opportunity all of his revenue
instead like i actually think he would
benefit more from like being sat down
and explained to
and i think like of all the people
who've been quote unquote cancelled like
he has done the most with the
opportunity that he's been given and i'm
so glad i gave him the benefit of the
doubt because like
i might even be a bigger fan than i was
before like just for someone who knows
how to like own up to their mistakes
and do and do the work and just be like
oh why was this wrong this is right okay
yeah so i'm always inclined to give
people the benefit of the doubt but
this does feel abyssal like a pattern
and i'm also inclined to give people the
benefit of that but like nick cannon
apologized
and then did some sat down with a rabbi
right yeah so
let's get there next story a little more
vaccine drama
is it the vaccine drama brought to you
by liquid iv
yes you all probably know liquid iv for
their popular hydration mix
their energy multiplier is an absolute
gem a game changer and gives you a
little extra boost
that you all need because 2020 was rough
it's time to clean the slate and start
20 21
off on the right foot one stick is like
drinking two cups of coffee it's an
all-natural alternative
to processed energy drinks for a
sustained energy boost throughout the
day
so actually i love the liquid iv
products but i really like this one in
particular because i don't drink coffee
i've never really cotton to
drinking coffee like i don't like the
taste and i heard it stunts your growth
but sometimes it's like you're crashing
you need an energy
supply and i think that this liquid iv
product is fabulous because
i'm part of more than half of americans
that struggle with daily fatigue
if you have decreased focus a lack of
motivation poor mood on happiness
the liquid iv energy multiplier can
upgrade your vibe and reach a constant
state of awesome so
its premium matcha and green energy
blend taste delicious and provide
lasting energy throughout the day
liquidity is also on a mission to change
the world positively so you can feel
good knowing that
every time you purchase the company has
donated over 10 million servings
10 million servings globally excuse me
in response to covenant 19 over 4
million products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active u.s military
grab your energy like would i be in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code
toast at checkout that's 25 off anything
you order when you use promo code toast
at liquidive.com
start fueling your adventure today at
liquidive.com promo code toast
um i'm very excited to talk about this
story and like warning i feel very
passionately about it okay and so
if you are like a really sensitive
person who like you know thinks talking
about the vaccine is like taboo
please turn off because you're not gonna
like what i have to say okay let me take
it from the top okay
amanda cloots is receiving backlash and
shaming
for getting the covid19 vaccine amanda
cloots has responded to social media
followers who took issue with the
fitness pro getting vaccinated following
the death of her husband nick cordero
last summer we spoke
about amanda cloots last year her
husband passed away from coven 19 after
a
very long battle with the disease he was
40 he was
in good health he was a broadway actor
broadway actor and she like started this
social media campaign like just
she couldn't see him never saw him she
was facetiming with his nurses
but she like remained so positive she's
just been like a beacon of hope when
like
i don't like she's one of the people
who's had such a hard time
in the pandemic and lost so much and
she's a hero and she's now a host
of the talk great so the daytime talk
show personality shared a photo of
herself receiving the coven 19 vaccine
on friday night
upsetting many fans as only essential
workers in residence over 65 are allowed
to take the vaccine in la at this time
someone said can you explain why you got
the vaccine ahead of 65 year olds and
first responders here in la that can't
get them yet
inquiring minds want to know how you got
your vaccine while those working in
school
in schools still cannot even book an
appointment so then
she amended the caption on her instagram
post to explain how
and why she got the vaccine she said i
went to a site and waited in my car
until all appointments were over
in hopes that they had any extra
vaccines i was fully prepared to be
turned away but they said they had
enough tonight for everyone waiting
i cannot tell you how emotional i was
and still am right now
she said that she's been terrified since
nick has passed as a single mother
of getting the virus and now i am one
step closer i'm sorry
she doesn't owe me an explanation okay
here's what first of all
what people may not know especially new
york do you know how many vaccines
they're throwing out every night
because if they they have to def freeze
them thaw they thaw
so if somebody makes an appointment and
doesn't show up or moves their
appointment
they can't use that thing tomorrow so
right at the end of the day
if there's certain uh vaccines that go
unused they get thrown in the trash
which is why young people have been
standing outside these warehouse
these facilities for hours hoping that
maybe someone didn't show up or maybe
there's a leftover
that instead of throwing it away which
is so stupid this person can get
vaccinated and that's exactly what
amanda klutz did right there's literally
nothing wrong with it and amanda cloots
has been through enough
leave her alone leave her alone agreed i
have no issue with someone who wants to
go and wait and get a vaccine that would
have been thrown in the garbage
yeah also i'm a part of this thing tbg
told me about it
so they you put your phone number in
your uh like
social security number your address and
everything and
then if there is a vaccine at a facility
in your area
that is going to be thrown away they
text you you have 15 minutes to answer
and brilliant
two hours to get to the facility so it's
saving these doses that would otherwise
be thrown away which is
so stupid like i can't believe that
we're throwing away vaccines
so people are doing this this is not
illegal
it's fine and also like i think there's
a lot of you know
questions around who's getting vaccines
i think people are cutting lines i think
people are lying
if you want to talk about that that's a
separate conversation um
but if you're not lying or paying your
way or cutting lines like
i have no issue with you getting a
vaccine that would have gone in the
trash
yeah and it's just like please we're
coming and good for her for being
transparent like
she's been sharing her whole journey
when i spoke on the toast like six
months ago about how like i definitely
feel like some celebrities are like
getting the vaccine like yeah they're
private doctors i got so many dm's like
yeah i work for a publicist i work for a
celebrity like my boss got it like
this is a thing celebrities are doing
they're being shady about it whatever
amanda clutch is being transparent and
she did nothing wrong so like really
we're gonna [ __ ] attack this woman
after all she's been through leave her
the [ __ ] alone now
no but also a vaccine in the arm of
anyone is is
more contributes more to us getting
through this pandemic than a vaccine in
the garbage
oh my god so beautifully said i don't
know what i stuttered
you want to say it again no i didn't do
it again do it again
and add some like a vaccine in the arm
of anyone
contributes more to us ending the
pandemic than a vaccine in the garbage
you're so right thank you no i'm also
just like done with this
like you don't know what people are
going through you don't know someone's
health like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] off leave everyone alone
everyone is just doing their best
and if you don't like what someone's
doing maybe you should just unfollow
them
silently i really think that no one
knows what amanda includes health is
nobody knows what what this last year
has been like like please like let's
just leave everyone alone like
it's just exhausting like having all
this energy to like
backlash like where do you get the
energy i can barely get out of bed in
the morning 100
leave amanda clutch alone i feel we must
protect her stop
now claudia said stop and she did
nothing wrong mm-hmm
let's reserve our energy like in fact i
would i know what i would venture to
argue that
more people should be getting vaccines
that would be thrown in the garbage
of course by the way every vaccine that
gets thrown in the garbage like kill me
mm-hmm that could have been me i have
something else to say
all this energy like these social media
trolls have for like
maxine like i would love to see them
give half the energy to like
actual bad people do you know anything
right right and i don't know if this is
a story and i'm not saying
you know whatever but um have you been
keeping up with this crystalia
stuff no so like a year ago
there were like a couple social media
accounts that started like um
gathering stories of women who had had
very bizarre
interactions online and real life with
crystalia
he released a statement and like went
totally m.i.a
and now he's back he has a podcast so he
released like a nine minute video
and i also think it was an audio but i
watched the video i'm just kind of
addressing the claim saying stating that
like everything
he that was all of his relationships
have been legal and consensual but like
he understands like why i was like
a little [ __ ] up to like abuse his
power honestly
the apology like on the surface seemed
genuine and then you're like listening
to his words and it's like what are you
actually saying like there's no
substance to the words like he was just
talking in circles um and i was just
like reading the comments and it was
just like
so much grace being given it's like
where's that grace for amanda cloots
like why are
like people on the internet are just so
inconsistent you know like it bothered
me so much
and it's like where's the grace you know
where's all these people coming out to
like support
you know the women who spoke out against
him like it was just like it kind of
bothered me like a lot
i feel that sorry i know they're like
not the same i'm just saying like
backlash i'm i'm saying like
there we need to have the same energy
for like people who we think you know
got the vaccine wrong
for like actual bad people yeah well i
would say not the same energy
right thank you no thank you yes okay
are you ready for our next story i think
it's going to turn your frown upside
down
i'm i'm so much looking forward to that
garrett hudlund is talking about tim
mcgraw being the godfather to his and
emma robert's son
what yes the actor explained on the
kelly clarkson show just the story gets
better and better
why he and emma chose country star tim
mcgraw as the godfather to their new son
rhodes robert
okay but so for those who don't know
like garrett hedlund knows tim mcgraw
from country strong but also because
they did a movie together in 2004 called
friday night lights
which i think is like friday night
lights oh my gosh they've been in two
movies together right and he explains
how he looks up to mcgraw
whom he has worked with sit since 2004
on friday night lights and country
strong in 2010.
he said he's somebody that i admire and
respect not only as an amazing father
and an amazing husband amazing musician
and amazing actor
i've known him for a long time we laugh
about it because it's probably been over
17 years since we did friday night
lights together we played father and son
so i got to first experience him as a
father in that film somewhat more of an
abusive one but then we did country
strong together and we've remained such
close friends and you know i've seen his
children his daughters from the time
they were one
three and five so now he's the godfather
to
rhodes robert wait that's so stunning
first of all i love this friendship
garrett headlong is just like such a
major hottie
and now he's like a daddy and i'm loving
the respect he's putting on tim mcgraw
and you know if i had a friend as rich
as tim mcgraw i too would make him the
godmother and father of my child
yeah the mother and the father yeah of
course it's such an honor give them both
totally this is just like the sweetest
story also like maybe
we're going to be angling for a country
strong sequel imagine
no it's like no one even cares about the
first one it's [ __ ] disrespectful
that's not true
i just have to say i i care and i spread
the gospel
all the time like i actually just made
my friend jason watch it i'm like it's
literally better than a star is born
he's like really i'm like yeah
he loved it he couldn't believe like
he had never seen it before and i just
feel like i'm personally responsible for
like at least 100 people who love
country strong that's good
and by the way i don't know if you guys
know i'm actually like friendly with
gwyneth paltrow and she loves the movie
like
she she should she should be so and she
knows there's like a small but
passionate following
and she really appreciates us i'm dead
serious she reposted me uh
singing country strong at your writing
on her instagram right and also like a
story like this shows us that like the
cast loves it too it was a good
experience for them as it was for us yes
like they are
family yeah no that's beautiful like
next thing we hear is like leighton
meester is the auntie you know
oh my god i would love to see that i
would love like a reunion of leighton
tim garrett and gwyneth like all i don't
know maybe like when it's like a huge
house in malibu i don't know if that's
where she lives but yeah
i assume she's a predator also emma you
know that
madame brad foul chuck would come adam
brody would come
face hell faith hill would come like
iconic foursome
iconic we gotta set it up i'll host
okay ready for our fifth and final story
it's a little housewives news a little
hwm
a little hwn brandi redmond is
leaving real housewives of dallas
question mark she posted a very
long cryptic message on her instagram
saying sometimes things come to an end
it does seem as though like that was her
announcing her departure also stephanie
posted like a photo of them like love
you brandy so
i feel like this was an announcement
just like wrapped in
in a bible verse in a bible verse yeah
it was confusing
and i was thinking about it and while i
i'm saddened because i love brandy
i do think at the present moment she's
not adding
much to the storyline and i do think she
has a lot going on in her personal life
like her mother-in-law just passed away
she was in a car accident with one of
her children the child was okay
and then she just had another baby so i
just feel like there's actually a lot
going on in her life like maybe it's
worth her taking a step back
because she used to be like the straw
that stirs the drink and now i just feel
she's kind of on the outside of the
story line yeah but it's also
interesting and and strange that she
is announcing this in the middle of the
season i wonder why that is i feel like
there is something to this story
but i don't know yeah um i'm gonna miss
her i
miss her stephanie is like dynamic yeah
and i feel like she
maybe this didn't always come through on
the show but i feel like she contributes
so much to like the positive
energy and like fun that they have on
the show like the drunk vibes yeah and
it's like she's
like always you know she's everyone is
in such a good mood when brandy is
around and it's like that doesn't
translate to great television or
anything but like everyone being in a
good mood is always fun to watch that's
true no i do think that there's things
that
she definitely brings to the show and
that will be missed but overall i think
in the last few seasons
she's kind of faded from like the main
storyline like it used to be like her
and leanne remember me remember her and
stephanie like weren't friends and she
became friends with leon it was like the
portrayal of a lifetime
like i i do think that she's kind of
taking a step back from that because
it's exhausting to like always be
you know the one in the drama so now
it's like she's not irrelevant but
she's not pertinent yes i think she was
just like
being actually friends with everyone and
enjoying her time but like
that's not the whole show also her
husband doesn't like to film because
i mean i mean i remember her first
season the first season of the show like
he was just not translating well like he
was kind of coming off a dick when i
actually think they have like a good
marriage
yeah um but as oh that always happens
like remember bill aiden his first
season was like kind of a dick and now
i'm like so in love with him i would do
anything for him like
that is just kind of what happens with
husbands and sent on translate and some
do like i think travis does really well
so i think the fact that her husband
doesn't film and like they can't really
spend nights together when she's filming
it must be it's just not ideal anymore
yeah also a little more housewise i'm
just putting these two like small
stories together
is that according to page six everyone
and their mother is
auditioning for real housewives of miami
which makes complete sense i was
thinking about it like
everyone is moving a lot of like the
rich men and women the couples married
people here have moved from new york to
florida and that's exactly what
they're looking for housewives i think
if there was ever a time to bring back
real housewives of miami like now is the
time because i think there's a lot of
fabulous people
the social scene more fabulous than
there was i mean half the real
housewives of new york live in palm
beach
right but even like ariel charnes could
be a real housewife yeah
yeah that's a good i mean i don't think
she would want to be but no no but like
i just so many people are moving down
there i think that
the pool i'm sure it's fierce
competition i think it actually will be
amazing and i actually think it'll be
difficult for even the women who were
already cast like
i've heard that like lisa hochstein and
alexia like they have to audition again
yes and marisol
um is also angling for a return and even
larsa could be coming back page six is
saying
larson would be good just because like
she is
famous she's interesting but like is she
miami anymore
yes but she was looking for a house in
calabasas yeah
just sold that house i saw and she's
selling it with like all of her cars
that's why i was written up in tmz or
something
and she's moving back to miami i believe
oh well then i hope for her sake that
she and she actually is like
so miami yeah i'm just confused by her
finances because like
yes she was married to scottie pippen
like
one of the highest paid basketball
players of all time like does that make
you rich as a divorcee i don't know
i think maybe they had a prenup i think
so okay i hope so
yeah i believe so um i believe in a
thing called love
and those are the fastest stories and i
feel as though you needed to know them
yes and to continue on our housewives
tour
i am so excited to talk about the real
housewives of atlanta which is brought
to you by fashion pass a clothing rental
service that we've heard that i actually
heard about
from you and margot like two years ago
maybe um
it's a kind of like rent the runway
meets revolve it's really fabulous they
have great brands like for love and
lemons
free people show me your moomoo it's the
revolve of rental services so if you
hate spending 200
on one dress or jacket that you can only
wear once
this might be for you they have a bunch
of different plans we're on the
trendsetter plan so we get three
clothing items and two accessories
in every box and we can switch out that
box as many times a month as we want
the shipping is very fast and they take
care of the dry cleaning so you know
that everything you're getting is clean
so you just have to throw it back
with a pre-pre-labeled bag and then um
when you're done and they'll choose new
items for you or you'll choose new items
and they'll ship it for you
um one of the best parts is that if you
love something and you want to purchase
it for your own
you get a great discount like anywhere
between 30 and 60 off so we've gotten a
couple really cool things that i just
rented but ended up purchasing because
i thought it would be great in my
wardrobe 100 and when your fashionistas
like us
and you take so many photos like your
models like us as well you need like a
never ending work rotation
and sometimes it's like that can be
really cost prohibitive
yeah so renting is really cost efficient
cost efficient i can't talk to them no
you can't but also like being
doing the show every day like it's
always fun to have new pieces but
one who has a space in their closet and
two who has the budget right so
fashion pass is fabulous and i also
believe that it is so toasty like the
clothing everything about it like i
think the toasters will love it check it
out
if you haven't already because it is the
solution to a very large problem
and they don't um do a lot of discounts
but today we have a special discount it
is the best deal they've ever offered
if you go to the fashionpass.com that's
the fashionpass.com
use code toast at checkout you get 50
off your first month so you can try
for the first time for literally 29.
again that's the fashionpass.com
code toaster check out you get 50 off
your first month so you can try it for
just 29.
love it okay let's talk okay so real
houses of atlanta i feel like we've been
on
this trip for so long like they're
really stretching out yes into episodes
now we know why
yeah and there was a lot to unpack i'm
gonna reserve like the sex party
stuff i just want to talk about like a
few random things okay before
i like love marlo hampton so much and i
really felt like she was genuine
in her like um reunion with kenny moore
and that was actually really nice to see
because i feel like kenya's just one of
my biggest frustrations with her is that
she's like incapable of having a genuine
moment
and so i'm glad they made up but i'm
also inclined to think like what is
kenya getting out of this like
why does she want marlo as an ally like
there's more going on
yes but i do think like it was a a
genuine moment at least
it was from marlo and then i was worried
that kenya was just gonna like you know
and can you started with that but you
said this and that and this and that
right and then they both
just like had this moment and i felt
like it was genuine and also
i do think that kenya is alienating
herself from
some of the other women and so it's a
good time to get a new friend
because toyah who's been like so up
kenya's ass
was for the first time like starting to
be like oh i know why everyone's been
always talking [ __ ] about kenny like
she's starting to annoy me right now
because toya was definitely involved in
whatever was going on in that open
bedroom
oh you think so that's not what that's
not the vibe that i got she
was exonerated from the trial because
she
um was on the instagram right tanya
allegedly and porsha kenya's working
theory is that it was tanya and portia
i i actually believe that it probably
was but porsha is going to protect tanya
because tanya has a fiancee and like
they were just having fun like it's a
bachelorette party but kenya it's just
like annoying me so much like i get that
first of all they went so we saw the
footage they went so out of their way to
like make this an off-camera thing and
even we're gracious enough to like talk
about it the next day on the show being
like oh
it's crazy but not like get into details
but can you just like it's like a dog
with a bone and like won't let it go and
she's trying to like out everyone
when like they're just having trying to
have a good time on the trip that you
planned like you wanted them to have fun
that's exactly what they're doing
yeah and i i hate that energy and like
any friend when it's like we all like
had a rowdy time and someone needs to
like go back
and remember every single thing and not
just like
let the fun night be the fun night like
sure let's like recap it but
to go to like how was it literal
investigation
as to what happened it's like no no
and it's not just like for fun like she
obviously knows what she's doing
yeah like not great intentions like she
wants to embarrass people right and also
a lot of these women are
relationships like if that were if i
were in that house i would
i do not like that no and so it's
starting to rub the girls the wrong way
now like by the end of the day the next
day they've all kind of
spoken to one another and they realize
that like kenny's just like not letting
this go like
they were just talking about like yeah
last night was so crazy so fun on camera
but they're not gonna go into it detail
the most they're gonna say is like what
time did you go to bed you know they're
not
getting into detail like who was kissing
who but kenya is just like trying to
paint this picture and it's like leave
everyone alone like these girls have
been cooped up at home for a year
they're going on a bachelorette party
okay they got a little wild leave them
the [ __ ] alone
isn't that the point of a bachelorette
party it is and so i feel like on the
one hand i feel like some people might
be conflicted about the producers like
using footage that they
that they went so far out of their way
to conceal to paint a picture
i think like that is the producer's job
like they had these few row camera
angles
and one angle of toya and porsche
kissing and they
didn't push the camera all the way out
but i feel like the things that the
producers were able to cobble together
like still weren't that damning like it
just shows a crazy fun night with bolo
but i think that what kang is doing is
like breaking
girl code friend code and also like
breaking like
co-star code reality star you know you
were with us in trying to like
keep this off camera yeah because she
was the one kenya was like go get bola
when bolo was done he went to like his
room i guess to change and leave
she was like she said to candy candy go
get bolo bring him back here
and then candy was the one who told the
producers like could we cut so we can
like actually have a good time
so kenya was almost not a catalyst but
she was definitely
you know involved in getting the knight
to where it got she was all over you
know spreading her legs on the floor
like she was down
she was like now you're gonna be like a
whistleblower yeah i i did not like it
what did you think about the way that
they filmed the
oh my god i thought it was hysterical
literally like emmys for everyone like
when they opened the episode and kenny
was smoking a cigarette and they were
like man you can't smoke in here
i just thought there were so many funny
elements to it and it was like a real
and it was clear that they had a lack of
footage
from the original night so they
supplemented it with like all these
other things and i actually think they
did a good job
i think they did a really good job i
also think that they had a lot of
footage i can just even
imagine like everyone all the producers
like combing through
hours of an outdoor camera to see what's
going on inside
zooming in to see who's who like that
must have taken they worked hard
days but i also thought like the episode
in other ways was just also really funny
like
when when they went fishing and then
they came home and porsha was like
now i feel like a man like if there's
not a sandwich in there for me like i'm
gonna kill someone
they were just being so funny and like
they really embrace themselves like
before the crazy night like in those
outfits just to like
make cynthia have a good time like i
just think it was really fun
and i'm like annoyed that kenya ruined
it because now that they look back on
that night with like a pit not with just
like oh it's crazy
of course with a pig it could have we
would have never found out about any of
this and the fact that all of this was
also in the news a few days later
like somebody linked it kenya yeah she's
really she's a major snitch energy
yeah and i'm glad porsha's mad at her
because porsha is my queen and like i
always agree with portia so like
whatever porsha does like i fully
support yeah
that's i stand by that yeah and i've and
i've been you know again the apologist
this season so far and i'm just
like i'm not here for this energy yeah
this is like the worst type of energy
you can have
snitch energy and you know i believe it
was marlo hampton said have you ever
heard
snitches get stitches it's so tricky and
that's literally what the episode should
have been called but i also loved the
scene i mean i was literally i was also
like unwell last night so watching them
be hung over and then drew on a fishing
boat drinking
and fishing and i was like i would like
i
actually would have thrown up because
like that time we were in nantucket and
we went on a boat and i like i didn't
even drink as much as they did i wasn't
even up as late as they were yeah and i
was throwing up off the side like i was
no they're my hero
they are heroes but also uh i think we
need to summer in south carolina like
need one of those houses
need to be on the beach need a boat yeah
the house is really amazing
gorgeous and they really haven't left
the house but like would you
no sickening no on the beach it's good
stuff
yeah so it was a great episode and then
i was just really thinking like between
jersey this episode of atlanta and this
most recent season of potomac like
housewives has been on fire
yeah with the exception of salt lake
city oh and salt lake city with the
exception of ocean
i think the season of dallas is good
yeah so they've really just been
but like in particular i think we're
having the best season of jersey potomac
and atlanta we've had in a while yeah so
that was exciting that is exciting i
just like cackled so many times during
the episode like porsha's
so funny and that's like why i feel like
atlanta kind of separates itself from
the other
shows is like the women are hysterical
like i find myself laughing
from their confessionals from like
random [ __ ] they say well like walking
up a flight of stairs
they're so funny and it's just
refreshing to like laugh
i agree so it was a great episode been a
really good season highly recommend
um don't forget our test movie of the
week we will be recapping on friday it
is our final one in honor of black
history month and we are watching
coming to america starring eddie
murphree eddie murphy
and garcelle um two more things one
merch is still available at
chatmorningtoads.com how you doing merch
and
redheads merch and people already
receiving their merch and they shed like
shipping sheets
it was sickening the mailbox down that's
what they said the mailbox was like this
i'm sick also even a patreon yes that's
what i was going to say my home tour
is so well done thank you so much i
finally filmed my home tour
um the new apartment that zach and i
moved into about two months ago and so
i'm taking
you through the whole house and showing
you some of our decorating choices
she's sporting a sickening ponytail
people are talking about the opponent
everyone's talking about the ponytail
and i have been doing my hair
differently and that was the result of
that
we could tell the energy wrap and i just
flip my ends up that's what i've been
doing with my hair and so when i put it
in that ponytail and it was like
day four it just flipped up at the end
which i
love um so thank you everyone for
noticing that i've been doing something
differently
and the home tour is up now at
patreon.com morning toast i do have to
say um
bruno is the star no i i mean uh
hollywood is a buzzing no quaking they
saw bruce they were like they're like is
he representative he's an agent who's
his publicist they're trying to get
there
is he on the loose yes the answer is yes
so if you want to see some sweet sweet
bruce head over to patreon.com
the morning toast and we also have two
other episodes already up this month we
did a deer toasters episode where
i think i know we say this every time i
think we gave the best advice we've ever
given really
yes i really do i was like thinking
about it the whole day after we filmed
it
i mean i have no memory i don't even
remember what we said because it was
like a week ago yeah no but
it was good and then also um the other
episode we did
was it a part two of the q a i don't
think so no what was the first episode
of the month
maybe it was general q a which everybody
always loves you can ask us anything and
maybe if you head over to patreon.com
you can find out what that episode was
yes for certain um thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the melania morning show where we
deliver the fast face stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
our podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch your public radio i
already have stocks all the places where
everybody listens to podcast find out
someone tells us a five star view about
how beautiful
stunning and smart we are i hope you
have a great day
bye